we're going in three two one
let's go get this son of a
hi everyone is Charlie this is going to be
my Avengers end game full review
hopefully you've had a chance to see the
movie everything we've been doing the
last 10 years in this universe has been
building to this so we got to talk about
everything about these character arcs
how we feel like they left these
characters how well their character arcs
work in general how well the movie works
just as a movie by itself because it is
a crazy big movie there's so much stuff
going on during this be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
it's only going to get crazier leading up
into spider-man far from home at the
beginning of July so there's going to be a
lot of Marvel stuff happening between
now and then we'll do a new round of the
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway all you have
to do to enter that is be a subscriber
and leave an Avengers comment on the
video obligatory spoiler warning careful
for spoilers for Avengers end game if
you have not seen it yet because we'll
be talking about very specific parts of
the movie so here we go Avengers end
game part of the story is the end every
story has an end that's why Kevin Feige
said that the biggest idea that they had
for this movie is wouldn't it be
revolutionary for superhero movies if we
actually had an end to their story
whereas in the traditional comic book
genre what you'll find is they'll just
reboot titles when they bring on new
artists or they'll have a big universe
reboot when they feel like things aren't
working or people aren't really
interested in the stories that they're
telling anymore like we're bringing in a
bunch of new artists we're just going to
wipe the slate clean and pretend like
all the things that happen to these
characters did not happen we're going to
start fresh from square one where they
really can't do that with the movies
like you have actors that are slowly
aging out of their characters people
like Chris Evans that are ready to stop
playing their characters so how do you
give them an ending to their story that
feels definitive and feels like the
right ending that fans won't just assume
you're going to roll back with the very
next movie that you released like
spider-man far from home is the next
movie that's coming out after this but
Kevin Feige is calling it the tail end
like a little holdover from Marvel phase
3 and not technically part of phase 4
that's a whole other thing there are a
couple plot twists during the movie that
leave you with a couple really big
questions coming out in terms of
Avengers movies every once in a while
you'll see something that seems like a
plot hole there are a couple moments
like that during Avengers end game but I
don't think of them so much as plot
holes just more unanswered questions
that they'll answer with the future
movies like Spider Man far from home
will answer all of your spider-man
questions that you have after avengers
endgame so the movie has a book in for
the last ten years of Marvel films what
they're calling the infinity saga the
last 22 films I feel like they did
provide a fairly definitive end it
definitely feels like an ending the way
they leave the characters but as a
longtime MCU fan not just a general
movie goer I feel like the movie was a
little more rewarding for me
because I recognized all of the Easter
eggs and references they baked in there
are a lot of moments during the film
when they're jumping around to different
points in the other movies from the MCU
where people might not recognize
references like why is the audience
laughing so much when Captain America
makes this very specific reference there
are even references to deleted scenes
from other Marvel movies that people
wouldn't recognize unless you're a
hardcore Marvel fan and you actually
watch all the deleted scenes and bonus
features from every single Marvel movie
so as an audience member going to see a
movie your mileage will vary depending
on how long you've been a Marvel fan and
how deeply you've been a Marvel fan I've
had a chance to see the movie again
since I posted my non-spoilery review
earlier this week after the premiere and
I will still say I double down on the
fact that it is a love letter to the
characters the original six Avengers
particularly and a love letter to the
fans but as a movie it feels a little
bit more like a big event piece like you
go to a theme park like Disneyland and
you experience the world of Marvel it's
kind of like that but put into a movie
and it's so different in terms of tone
and pacing than infinity war then a lot
of people who are just casual Marvel
fans might actually like infinity war
more than Avengers end game because
there's so much more character work
being done during Avengers end game
they're actually long stretches to the
film where there is no action scenes
it's really not too like the third act
so they get to the really big infinity
war level action but when they do it is
over the top and I will say that they
are getting a lot better at handling
those everybody at one scenes when
things get so crazy on screen so even
though it seems like they have hundreds
and hundreds of characters on screen at
the same time it still feels like you're
able to orient yourself and understand
what's going on and follow the action of
the main character that you're supposed
to be following during the scene so
here's where we got to get really
specific about the characters talk about
their arcs how we feel like they left
them up so we'll say careful for
spoilers one more time because we'll be
talking about the endings of these
characters starting with Captain America
one of my biggest surprises of the film
is that they did not end Captain
America because Chris Evans had been
talking about leaving the character for
so long like he wanted to just go up and
do other things before the film came out
the Bruce's are like well you know Chris
Evans might not be playing Captain
America anymore but he might not be
completely done in the MCU you'll
understand what that means after the
film comes out now we actually know what
that means he's actually going to
participate in a special Marvel what-if
TV show I'll talk about that when I talk
about more phase four stuff but he'll
continue to play Captain America in the
past in other projects so Chris Evans
will still be a version of Captain
America just not the one in present-day
because now we have old man cap and I
know there are a lot of questions about
the logic of how we wind up with old man
cap at the end of the movie because of
the way they use time travel during the
film I'll talk a little bit more about
the logic of the time travel when I do
Easter eggs and breakdown videos but I
do feel like they gave him a good ending
even if it wasn't the ending you wanted
it was a definitive ending for the
character they gave him a version of
what he'd been fighting for this whole
time like he has the conversation with
Tony during the film where he tells him
to get a life he has the kid he has
Pepper Potts you need to get a life like
me so he's sitting there thinking about
it and during the film he comes to the
conclusion so at the end of the film
when he goes back to be with Peggy
Carter it feels like something that he'd
wanted this whole time but just hadn't
been willing to let himself have for the
most part I've been seeing two reactions
to that story either people are happy
that he got that happy ending of sorts
or two they're just confused about the
logic of the time-travel talking about
Iron Man though obviously the other big
character of the film I said it earlier
this week all the actors bring their
a-game their performances are fantastic
and I think a little more rewarding for
longtime MCU fans like you have the cap
versus cap moment that really is
America's ass I could do this all day
yeah yeah I got it I know I've got eyes
on Loki that was actually the moment
referencing the Thor the dark world
deleted scene when Loki turned into
Captain America that I mentioned earlier
my opinions about the Iron Man arc are a
little bit different just because their
take on the Iron Man character in the
MCU is so different from comic book Iron
Man
so comic book Iron Man does not get
married he doesn't have any children
he does have successors but it's a very
Batman battle for the cowl situation
where people try to take up his
but nobody can ever quite measure up so
eventually Ironman himself finds a way
to come back like during Civil War to
where he winds up going into this weird
trance-like coma state then coming back
after they rebooted all the titles so a
lot of people went into the movie
expecting to see some twist like that
whereas dr. strange said there was the
only way that things could go down I
can't tell you what's going to happen
because if I do it won't wind up
happening and because Robert Downey jr.
is getting older and more expensive for
them to hire so I think part of the
reason for the way they let Iron Man go
out was to solve a bunch of practical
problems and to give him a definitive
end to the character a situation that he
would not try to weasel out of using his
intellect
maybe I'll wisecrack my way out of this
situation so I do commend them for
trying to do the revolutionary thing of
having consequences stick he uses the
gauntlet and they stick to the rules
that they set up during the movie it
almost ends Thanos to use the gauntlet
twice like you see him hobbling early in
the film like he's barely alive anyway
he's so weak then when the Hulk tries to
use it Hulk is completely messed up Fano
style like he doesn't heal the way Hulk
would normally heal so when you see a
normal person like Iron Man use it there
have to be consequences of course he's
not going to survive that moment and the
twist that they send him out on is just
as subversive as the twist that they
brought him in on like it was a really
big deal that a superhero would reveal
his identity openly to everyone I am
Iron Man and the press just explodes oh
my god he revealed his secret identity
it's a big deal that they actually stick
to consequences and let him go out using
the logic that they set up earlier in
the film comic book movies are famous
for ignoring the own rules that they set
up during films so I know there's a lot
of questions about the logic of certain
twists of the film but like Kevin Feige
said after infinity war we felt like we
never seen the heroes lose before people
feel like comic-book heroes always win
the heroes will always win well what
happens when they don't win
so that's your infinity war Empire
Strikes Back ending but like he also
said we also feel like people have never
seen an ending for these characters
would it be revolutionary if there was
an ending to their story so even if
you're not really happy about what they
did with the Ironman character and you
wanted it to go down a different way I
do give them extra points for trying to
do something so subversive like wow I
thought we were just going to keep
seeing versions of this character till
Robert Downey jr. was a hundred years
old how crazy that they would do it this
way one of the greatest lines of the
movie I love you 3000 I love that moment
with Iron Man and even if it is kind of
weird to see the character with the
child like I said very different from
comic book Iron Man I feel like he
completely sold those scenes with that
child actor largely I think that's just
because Robert Downey jr. is such a
fantastic actor and sold that stuff so
well for was also one of the more
controversial characters during the
movie your mileage will vary on Thor
depending on how much you like comedic
Thor some people just like really a
serious badass Thor some people like the
more emotionally accessible Thor that
gets to tell jokes and sort of be in on
the fun with everyone else I was
surprised at their choice to go with
thick Thor
thick with two seas you could give him
three seas he had a pretty big gut but I
feel like by the time they got to that
third action scene where you see him in
the background of shots they sort of
slimmed him down a little bit with CG
you probably been watching the movie and
watching Chris Hemsworth do all these
fitness videos on his Instagram the past
couple of weeks so it's really ironic to
watch it and see beer belly Thor while
Chris Hemsworth is being super fit in
real life I'm assuming they just used a
combination of prosthetics and special
effects to make him look fat during the
film it wasn't like Chris Hemsworth
gained 60 pounds during the span of a
couple weeks just to film these scenes
I'm really excited about the idea of as
guardians of the galaxy in future movies
I get what they were going for with his
character they wanted him to be just
completely dejected depressed not being
able to deal with what happened during
the movie not getting past his grief I
loved all the scenes that he got with
his mother obviously I loved all the
action scenes towards the end of the
film where he's duel building and then
we'll talk a little bit more about that
when I talk about the big action scenes
because some of the big twists like the
one with Thor's hammer was things from
the comics that we've been waiting for
this whole time so the movie tried to
pay off a lot of things that have been
happening they've been setting up for
the past 10 years
so that's why it feels like more of a
big event for the fandom instead of just
a traditional movie so I will rank this
with my top 5 maybe top 10 Marvel films
at the end of this I was a little upset
about what they did with the Hulk during
the film I loved professor Hulk Mark
Ruffalo is great as Professor Hulk just
like a very chatty more emotionally
accessible version of the character
because remember it's a blending of both
of their personalities so you get the
mind of Banner but he also gets some
the baser instincts of the Hulk which is
why he feels so chatty and he's telling
even more jokes because typically banner
is a little more reserved but there were
a couple of things during the movie that
they just completely sped through and
one of them was Professor hook like you
just show up and he's already Professor
Hulk they don't give you that moment he
explains it rather than them showing it
to you there were a couple moments
during the film that sort of drugged and
slowed things down a little bit that I
felt like they could have gotten rid of
in favor of giving you more big payoffs
with the characters like it would have
been better to spend more time with the
Hulk setting up the professor Hulk twist
than to watch ant-man walk all over the
place
learning about what happened after the
snap I feel like after he came out of
the quantum realm he could have just
gone straight to Cassies learned what
happened then gone straight to the
Avengers you don't really need all those
other scenes of him just wandering
around on the street looking at all the
devastation so it felt like they spent a
little too much time early in the film
waiting to build up to the team coming
back together but some of those early
Iron Man scenes when he first comes back
and he's still just a little bit crazy
from being stuck in space were fantastic
so I was happy that they included a
little bit of that the Black Widow
Hawkeye stuff during the film probably
the best scenes that we've gotten with
those characters in the last 10 years
their emotional arc during the film was
great Scarlett Johansson's some of her
best Black Widow especially early in the
film and then when she and Hawkeye are
arguing about who's going to take the hit
so that they can get the soulstone that
was perfect
and thankfully Hawkeye was not a joke
during the film there are a lot of
Hawkeye Easter eggs that we'll talk
about because he has that Marvel phase 4
TV show that's coming up that I think
that they were seating during this all
the cameos were great I loved the Stan
Lee cameo make love not war the funny
thing is is they dressed him up to look
like real-life 70s Stan Lee because Stan
Lee was very active during that period
the early 70s was when he transitioned
from working on regular comic books
every week to becoming the Marvel
publisher in Joe Russo's cameo was a big
surprise to jim Starlin also within the
same breath like you're on Joe Russo
then boom jim Starlin also in that same
support group I know there a lot of
questions about the logic of some of the
twists like they've sent some characters
out in a very definitive way but then
characters from the past come back into
present day so technically you still
have some versions of characters running
around so why then couldn't they go into
another timeline and gray
a past version of Iron Man in Black
Widow and bring them into present day
like us I'll talk about that more during
Easter eggs but I think mostly it's in
favor of giving them a definitive ending
and if they'd gone right back and got
another Iron Man in Black Widow it would
have completely trampled on the endings
that those characters got I was fine
with the way that they handled time
travel but you need to understand that
they're going with Dragon Ball Z Future
Trunks time travel rules they're not
going with Back to the Future or
terminator rules every time they go back
into the past and change something it
only creates another timeline it does
not change their future so the futures
that they go back to will always be the
same even though there were a lot of
questions they did not answer at the end
of the film and so much was happening
I'm sure you have a billion questions
about the ending of the film I did feel
like they stuck the landing they gave
all these characters a nice bookend it
feels like an end for the Avengers even
though there will be more Avengers films
it'll just be a new roster of characters
with some of them coming back and some
new ones being cycled in so he is it was
a great film I had a lot of fun watching
it I'll watch it a couple more times
just to catch all the Easter eggs but I
feel like just a lot more rewarding for
a longtime hardcore MCU fans as opposed
to casual movie goers that probably
enjoy infinity war more just for its
level of action and pacing so here's my
top 5 Marvel films after seeing Avengers
endgame a couple times starting with
number 5 the original guardians of the
galaxy film still feel like that's
better than guardians of the galaxy vol
2 for Avengers infinity war 3 avengers
endgame - the original Iron Man movie
there be no MCU if there was no
successful Iron Man I am Iron Man they
even sent him off on that very iconic
moment in then one my favorite is still
Winter Soldier which they referenced so
many times during the film so many of
the moments even when they were in 2012
were referencing Winter Soldier moments
hail Hydra
does anybody want to get off this
elevator so would you have a chance to
see the movie or if you've already seen
it just let me know where you rank this
movie with your other Avengers films
your favorite moments what you thought
about it what'll happen is this all name
a giveaway winner when I post my
breakdown Easter egg stuff happening
this weekend so more Avengers endgame
videos coming in the next couple of days
while you wait for everything click here
to learn about the next door film Chris
Hemsworth talking about Thor 4 and
click here for my Game of Thrones season
8 episode 3 video
thank you so much for watching I
Love You 3000 I'll see you guys tonight